[Musique]
tania s'est payé un téléviseur de 90
pouces l'eee mille dollars
pourtant après seulement quatre rangs de
téléviseurs où s'allume plus tania est
désespéré parce que la garantie du
manufacturier est échue depuis longtemps
mais en faisant des recherches elle
découvre l'existence de la garantie
légale on dit garantie légale parce que
dans certaines provinces comme le québec
et le nouveau brunswick
la loi exige qu'un bien pu servir
pendant une durée raisonnable
raisonnable c'est bien beau mais ça veut
dire combien de temps les juges
répondent souvent ici question
il existe donc plusieurs jugements à ce
sujet le fils de la protection du
consommateur a eu la bonne idée de les
compiler à titre indicatif
tania a consulté ses décisions et elle a
vu hélas un recours si le détaillant une
manufacturier refuse de régler son
problème
elle pourrait obtenir réduction du tigre
ou un remboursement des réparations les
remous de l'histoire même si l'achat est
extravagant la durée de vie elle doit
être raisonnable